Speaker 1: All right. Let's talk to people
from the audience. We do this via discord at
David Pakman dot com slash discord. We have so
many people waiting to chat. So let's not delay
any further. Let's really get right into it. Why
don't we first talk to and again, this is just
first, let's talk to Drew from New York. Drew,
welcome to the program. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 3: But can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 3: Wonderful. It's great
to be here my first time on call.
Speaker 1: Great. What's going on today?
Speaker 3: So first question, given that
right now they're doing, I think, the
fourth ballot for the House. Why do you
think that over under is for 12 ballots?
Speaker 1: Honestly, I have no idea. And
by the time this airs will almost
certainly know what the outcome
was. So I don't even want to wade into that.
Speaker 3: It's fair share. I've had I've been
holding on for since the midterms. So I don't
know. I don't. I hope you don't mind if I ask
it. Not at all. So in your opinion, what do you
think was the biggest single upset for any of any
of the individual elections from the midterms?
Speaker 1: Oh, you know what? My memory goes
blank. Like five days after any event until
I review the biggest upset. Well, I mean,
in a sense, it was even though she still won
the narrow margin that Lauren Boebert ended up
going by like it wasn't an upset and that she
still came away a winner, but it was such a
slim margin. So I, I mean, I think that that
was very interesting. There were a number of
races where the margin was was much smaller for
the Republican than expected. And it just all
kind of goes to is MAGA deflating and we'll we'll
know probably pretty soon if the answer is yes.
Speaker 3: Makes them make sense. I had
always had it in mind that for me though,
it was the Wisconsin governor, not
just the fact that he was able to win,
but by the margin that he was able to.
Speaker 1: Yeah, that's that's a good
one. That that may be it. Yeah. I would
have to review. You caught me off guard,
but there were a number of them. Drew.
Speaker 3: Right. And the last one this
should be quick given with the last midterm
election being decide with the runoff,
would you rather be a vampire or a werewolf?
Speaker 1: Well, I think I would rather be a
werewolf because the idea of drinking
blood is very unappealing to me.
Speaker 3: That's true.
Speaker 1: Yeah, that would that
wouldn't work for me, I don't think. All right.
All right, my friend. Thank you for the call.
Thank you. All right. There goes Drew with a
number of questions. We always love to see that.